Christmas dinner for me is not about
food piled high on a plate less is more
I'd rather have five or six things on a
play that takes absolutely delicious
then ten items tasting average stuffing
for instance I'd much rather put a lot
more effort into the stuffing and enjoy
it but eat a lot less of it first and
point mints to the bowl season with salt
and pepper and mix take your grater and
a braver an apple just get the grater
and grate the apple in there usually
stuffing is cooked in the turkey but I'm
doing mine separately so I can make in
advance and get the flavor and
presentation spot-on now the nice thing
about the Apple it goes brilliant well
with the pork makes it a little bit
sweeter it also makes it a lot lighter
as well which is really important
next add a handful of chopped apricots
which gives the stuffing another fruity
note and a lovely texture the Apple
disintegrates
but the apricots stay really nice intact
nice little bite then chop a handful of
pistachio nuts again I'm thinking of the
build up of textures flavor and also
color
pistachios in now give that a really
good mix grating some lemon zest the
zest is packed full of intensely
flavored essential oils which gives the
stuffing a vibrant citrus thing and for
freshness had a handful of coarsely
chopped parsley the balance of flavors
is nice and delicate and it sits
beautifully with a turkey now
sage and pork and apple that's the
perfect marriage now I'm going to think
about the presentation skills Tim for a
little drizzle of olive oil and then we
got a real nice fragrant sage leaves
the sage leaves are used to wrap the
stuffing start by overlapping them
it's almost like rolling cigar but we're
gonna roll it and sage leaves taste is
paramount but presentation is really
important to says we're spending a few
extra minutes to get this right because
it will make the final dish look amazing
now a little seasoned across the top and
then take your sausage meat I want to do
now is put half it onto the plate
just when you run your finger along with
stuffing this is where it takes on a
completely different flavor again I need
some spice in there on a little bit of
heat in the stuffing so it's exciting to
eat myrrh gays myrrh gays are
traditional North African sausages made
from beef or lamb and all going to do
now is take the sausage and lay that in
the middle they're flavored with harissa
a fiery chili paste which gives them the
heat and distinctive color it really
does give that nice sort of wake-up call
inside the stuffing if you can't get
hold of myrrh gays other spicy sausages
likes fries Oh would work well to take
the rest of stuffing and we'll set that
on top so in cases that mur gays
what you go to like that lifts up the
Tim fall very carefully and roll that
over let the temple do the work roll it
nice and tight there
fingers underneath just pull that back
and double-check lovely look at it I
even couch it and it looks delicious the
ultimate Christmas cracker fantastic
that sage will cook and really perfume
the sausage meat and you cut through the
center got a nice spicy sausage lovely
in now roll it across twist at the ends
and then from there up into the hands
and you push it in and twist and turn
and all that's doing it's just making
the perfect cylinder beautiful the
stuffing can be made wrapped and stored
in the fridge a day or two in advance
that's the first part of my ultimate
Christmas dinner ready on Christmas Day
simply pop it into the oven and cook at
200 degrees for 40 minutes
takes a very very very lean bird and it
dries out so so important to make sure
that we help it to cook perfectly nice
and sugar balsamic vinegar that's
something so tasty
baste those figs because the skin gets
nice and crispy on the outside